geniez efira bonjour bonjour au réel
bonheur de parler enfin de benedetti
alors on va quand même rappeler donc ça
fait quatre ans que le film a été tourné
vous êtes heureuse de présenter ce film
enfin ian oui je m'étais habitué à ce
qu'ils sortent jamais vous pouvez me
dire c'est forcément chez deux puisque
personne ne le verra jamais ben écoute
ouais ouais bah ouais je suis content qu
alors quel souvenir du tenue tour
d'horizon affaire concerne tournage
tellement marquants mais réellement
tellement marquants d'abord parce que
c'est paul verhoeven d'abord et surtout
est presqu'exclusivement parce que c'est
paul verhoeven qui d'abord pour moi un
des meilleurs cinéastes vivants ou monde
mais c'est à dire que j'étais folle de
lui quand j'avais 16-17 ans et ce qui
s'inscrit profondément dans
l'adolescence reste donc folle de lui
c'est un tournage comme j'ai
l'impression qu'on en fait pratiquement
plus très 90,70 c'est à dire de l'argent
et du temps pour un propos oblique et je
sais pas un tournage c'est le mot qui me
vient un peu pompeux mais j'essaie
d'expliquer de spirale vertueuse
c'est-à-dire que comme tous les jambes
l'admirais professionnellement et
humainement et que les huits vu son âge
vu son expérience il n'a pas peur que
quelqu'un lui enlève une partie de son
travail c'est que les autres peuvent
juste lui apporter quelque chose ils
tellement sûr de sa radiation est tout
nouveau volet du coup se mettre un
certain niveau et du coup c'était
vraiment une harmonie parfaite donc les
souvenirs me semble pas si l'on attend
c'est inscrit profondément mais dans ma
mémoire
vous étiez déjà au casting de l dans un
rôle de femme très pieuse
est-ce que vous avez été étonnés quand
il nous a carrément proposé johansson
bah disons que c'était dans une formule
profiter au large
oui j'étais étonné qu'on me propose le
rôle peut-être pas parce que c'était une
nonne mais peut-être parce qu'elle a un
côté machiavélique supposé ou réel et
que les acteurs sont souvent parfois
assimilé une typologie de personnages et
moi j'étais j'étais à bord plus de
plutôt sympa tosh quoi vous aviez on
vous a souvent vu dans un registre girl
next door en tout cas la paca mais oui
oui oui vous avez moins vu dans ce
registre là où est très ambigu jusqu'au
bout d'ailleurs je vous demanderais
peut-être en fin d'interview d'ailleurs
ce que vous pensez vraiment donné bêta
mais qu'est ce que vous aimez chez ce
personnage on va être déjà ce dont vous
venez de dire ce qui est peut-être
l'adjectif qui la caractérise le mieux
c'est l'ambiguïté elle n'est pas
cernable à un endroit peut pas justement
dire elle est comme ci comme ça là
benedetta non à l'esa est autre chose
tout le temps tout le temps peut-être
que ce qui me touche le plus haut si
c'est sa foi en fait c'est la croyance
c'est la croyance la plus ultime alors à
ce que l'on fait une utilisation
toujours bonne non mais même année sa
croyance c'est la foi c'est celle qui
avec dieu mais c'est aussi une
transcendance personnel c'est à dire une
volonté de s'élever aussi un endroit où
haut à cette époque est certainement
d'un milieu clérical et à cette époque
aussi les femmes étaient réduites à rien
quoi vous le dit souvent avec humour
mais jouer une vierge à 40 ans avoue
avoir abusé au boulot quand même je me
disais moi qui sait que bombe à mon âge
des premières fois sont plus rares en
valais mais je me dis que tout est
peut-être une dernière fois pour
sacraliser tournage enfin et un truc
monsieur là je vous dis ça c'est
certainement la dernière fois que
j'aurai une vierge
j'appelle premier enfin première et
dernière fois à quoi paul verhoeven donc
on le connaît c'est un réalisateur
sulfureux il ya beau des scènes très
très sensuelle dans le film comment est
ce que vous avez vécu le tournage
comment est ce que vous allez diriger
comme ça s'est passé
pas hyper bien c'est intéressant de
faire des scènes d'amour et de sexualité
par un cinéaste que ça intéresse qui
sait regarder c'est toujours comme on
regarde qui est important et lui c'est
vraiment il a fait des choses qui
étaient assez fondamentale là dedans
donc il y avait un storyboard on savait
par on devait passer si je puis dire
mais avait une possibilité d'imaginer
des choses aussi une scène réussie comme
ça c'est pas juste
l'érotisme ce fossile l'intimité qu'est
ce que c'est que l'intimité des corps
est presque un truc métaphorique
donc il y avait toutes ses dimensions là
et on pouvait chercher tous ensemble et
c'était assez joyeux en fait
et puis dans la danse dans le regard de
besné des tables justement dans ces
scènes de sexe on sent toute l'ambiguïté
de ce personnage et vous gardez ça même
dans ces scènes tellement intime
oui bon mois ce qui était rigolo à faire
aussi c'était l'idée que découvrir la
jouissance est peut-être à ce moment là
aussi c'était comme si tout d'un coup
ils se sentaient plus péter après ça
bien c'est vraiment un monde nouveau
s'ouvre à moi
alors c'est vrai que paul verhoven on le
sait les femmes sont souvent au centre
de ses fils pour vous c'est un
réalisateur féministe complètement
on est complètement mais c'est à dire
même avant de savoir ce qu'était le
féminisme est hors jeu pas sûr qu'à une
seule définition
mais même avant d'avoir une conscience
que je pourrais appeler féministe moi je
quand j'avais 15 ans
j'avais pas lu simone de beauvoir ou
autres mais au fait le fait d'avoir vu
peut-être mais enfin je ça a commencé
basiquement justement avec baiser comme
sting qui était le premier qui m'a fait
découvrir après tous les autres il y
avait déjà même là dedans une femme qui
pouvait être à la fois désirable et
désirante une femme qui pouvaient
inverser les rapports de domination une
femme qui qui ne se sentait pas coupable
de son corps ni tes désirs
donc c'était en fait des référents
peut-être pas intellectuel mais à ses
fondamentaux
ouais assure oui quel genre de directeur
d'acteur il est et dans quelle langue
vous intéressez vous avez parlé on verra
alors nous ne peut parler en flamand
j'ai un peu équipe à loos kubrick et
j'ai même pas sûr que ça soit juste en
anglais un peu mais non et surtout il
parle bien français
ouais donc vous avez vu comment ça
voulait dire quoi j'ai tout oublié et
dans lequel jean yves d'acteurs lalaye
quand je vais demander au départ
et qu'en est il de la préparation il y
avait quand même des grandes scènes de
possesion de machin c'est pas comme si
j'avais vécu ça tous les jours nous mène
quoi alré suisse si thomas bon ouais il
ya quelque chose à ma fille ne
s'allumait parle en anglais pour le coup
parce que je me souviens de cette phrase
tu sais ce que tu dois faire
j'ai pas dire ben non pas du tout donc
j'ai fait web y furent donc j'ai créé
mon côté en fait et puis je faisais des
propositions et souvent à la fin il
faisait assez bizarrement sapiens je
cours mais l'idéal ça bizarrement ça
bien j'encourage donc l'été qui laisse
quand même une liberté de création de
total je vous l'avais dit tout à l'heure
je vais vous poser une question en fin
d'interview donc benedetta c'est une
manipulatrice ou une sainte
c'est pas leur veine il a sa réponse il
a son lit n'est en tout cas pas
partageable concertent âge la même je
crois les deux un peu des deux un peu
des deux alors là évidemment sur 10 ni
manipulatrice saintes on se dit attends
une sorte d forcément n'est pas mais la
manipulatrice donc une simple c'est pas
un mot qui sert mot qui convient un peu
de gens comme m
parler de ça voudrait dire que
qu'est qu'on peut avoir un individu qui
n'auraient aucune part de mal en lui qui
ne serait que dans une solidarité de
chaque instant bon complexe quand même
mois les manipulatrices eu ces mots pas
dire à bonn non et c'est ce qui rend le
film passionnant merci beaucoup merci à
vous